[Music]
permission to come aboard captain
permission granted it's 2019 it's the
tenth anniversary of the Star Trek mmm
2009 Star Trek how do you feel that that
film changed the trajectory of your
career if it did well you know when they
asked me if I could you know if I would
get involved in Star Trek you know it my
first thought was when am I ever gonna
get a chance to do anything like this
you know it's really you know the idea
of doing that or another one or getting
involved in Star Wars which is obviously
a very different thing but still sort of
a space adventure it just felt like you
know a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
and to get to work with that cast was so
amazing the crew was just extraordinary
and I can't believe it's been 10 years
but but but you know that group is
really still like a family and so I just
feel very lucky to be part of it yeah
it's been 10 years since 2009 Star Trek
and of course JJ Abrams is busy with
another space adventure
rounding out the skywalker saga with
Star Wars Episode nine yet he still
finds time for more passion projects
he's now a producer on the play that
goes wrong a show he was introduced to
while working in a galaxy far far away
but once we are not here to talk about
Star Wars but I hear there is a Star
Wars connection with the play that goes
wrong and how you got introduced to it
while we were shooting the force awakens
in London and I needed a day off and so
I just bought a ticket to this play that
I saw was playing and I just don't
remember laughing that hard in the
theater and the audience was going crazy
and I got to know the producers and I
just offered if there was any way I
could help out
bring the plate of the states I'd love
to and it's just it's been incredible
fun now can you talk a little bit about
what the premise is it's kind of in the
title but what what exactly goes on in
this one this story is that there's this
amateur theatre company that's putting
on a very straight British murder
mystery and literally everything that
can go wrong does and it's just is a a
preposterous we funny
not just premise but the execution of
the thing the way the things
choreographed it was written by the
performers and so there's this kind of
like what I saw at the feeling I had was
I don't understand how this was made
because didn't feel like it was a play
that was just being put on
like this kind of like concoction that
somehow was created and it was because
the people doing it were the creators
and I sort of came they started doing it
in the pub in this little 20-minute you
know piece and they sort of expanded it
for the play it is actually can get kind
of dangerous if they're not careful but
it's amazing how much has to go right
for it to go wrong and you watch
backstage it's a remarkable it's a it's
a dance like to see how intricately
choreographed the thing is but it's
brilliantly done and incredibly funny
[Music]